to being single forever and ever and
ever
what video is this today we are
reviewing Valentine's Day gifts and we
are not qualified to do so I am as the
people say alone but not lonely I am
alone and a little bit lonely fun just
ready to cry this capsule we are an
objective party here to tell you how
dumb your gifts are to each other
Oh does it long-stem roses flowers
always smell nice they do smell good but
also kind of smell like a funeral home
don't what are you doing Kelsey I was
gonna do she loves me she loves me not
if you just give me some flowers that's
enough she loves me she loves me not
you went you got the flowers you thought
of me blossom she'll uh my wine just in
general
send your friend flowers why not I'm
gonna drunk send all of my friends
flowers come on you see she loves me
surprise Wow Wow prize guys she brought
me wine and flowers probably gonna give
it up oh I see chocolate hang up on it
thanks but you don't love me yes it
going straight to my hips the one thing
I don't like about these chocolate is
that you don't know what you're getting
and then I try it I'm like this gift
tells me ooh kind of forgot that I had
to do something for Valentine's Day so
I'm gonna get this this is more
acceptable for me in looks a fan or milk
from you got me chocolate milk from now
on that would be awesome this would be a
note from me dog that being said I'm
gonna have another now I'm hungry
actually this is all delicious you all
right take it back good dope yeah you
gave me this I would laugh a lot and I
would wear these with you as a joke one
time and then we would never use them
again with four leg holes this is
hilarious we're gonna try it on this is
happening
this is not sexy two people can't
comfortably fit in this a boner a nice
ass and two human bodies cannot
comfortably fit in here where do you buy
can't I can't not put my head like
there's gonna way to not be sexy with
this ooh
dad no wonder we're single I know dumb
[ __ ] we die don't joke gifts will be
awesome there's my girlfriend got me a
joke gift I love it now I'm like a baby
Joey I'm like a baby kangaroo
it starts off silly but if I was gonna
have sex with Zach right now I'd be
having the most fun sex I could have
that's the most action I've gotten all
year same love this movie the network
dances the notebooks great you don't do
a 4-pack I'm sorry but who has a DVD
player anymore this isn't for
Valentine's Day this is for single
people this is for Halloween watch he
built her a house and yet some people
still don't watch my Instagram story I
know we just don't like movies though
no I like movies but you won't take me
to a movie and I get me a movie this is
a threat this is like if you break up
with me you'll never have this these are
all sad stories you know what I would
love spacejam you just stay with me stay
with you
what for look at us we're already fight
well that's what we do we fight right
you tell me when I'm being an arrogant
son of a [ __ ] but I tell you what
you're being a pain in the ass is that
what all of you a while we're forever
you and me all the days go I lost you
let's go I think I could do it again you
can't you know you wanna do it don't
play me
[ __ ] you Ryan Gosling I'm gonna cry
Nicholas Sparks might be the reason I'm
alone dun dun dun dun
don't don't know the cynic in me says a
cheesy but then the romantic in me is
like yeah Valentine's Day proposal I
would just be like [ __ ] you don't
propose on Valentine's Day
you don't propose on Christmas and you
don't propose on my are yours birthday
those are
staple holidays that belong to Jesus
Christ Cupid me and you and not in that
or
we make me the happiest man in the world
yes yes yes yes a million times yes wait
is it the right of the left
I like diamonds jewelry is good I'd say
again customize it to the person so
subscribe something on it inscribe I
still like the idea of Valentine's Day I
hate that none of these things are going
to be for me just like love man
I'm happy for people who are in love and
I'm happy for myself because I love
myself damn straight
do whatever you want I don't know why
are you asking us we don't know anything
that's well yeah we're the worst people
to ask this it's all about your
intention and showing that you really
care and wear a condom oh god you don't
want kids yet you're not ready you're
not ready will you be my backup
Valentine I'd be an honor your judge now